the world is absolutely fixated on the
queen's jubilee celebrations marking her
70th anniversary on the throne but why
was the monarch missing today welcome to
entertainment tonight nichelle turner is
off day two kicked off without the queen
and arcadey nickel was in the middle of
it all
there was a chair it wasn't quite as
loud as for william and kate
[Music]
all eyes were fixed on the sussexes
today this was megan's big moment draped
in white dior for her first formal
public appearance in the uk since makes
it she held hands with harry for much of
the time there were smiles for the
cameras cheers and a few boos from the
crowd less than 15 months after their
bombshell oprah interview
the relationship is
space
so is the royal rift alive from the
looks of it the answer could be yes the
air and the spare sat very far apart
william and kate were front row beside
prince charles and camilla harry and
megan were all the way over on the
opposite side second row
while williams seemed reserved and
appeared not to speak to his brother
harry bantered with his cousins and was
in good spirits the last time the fab
four were seen side by side in march of
2020 and they appeared frosty so was the
palace avoiding a repeat well it appears
to be a case of some very clever
choreography because we have yet to see
the royal brothers reunited
the queen who didn't allow harry and
megan on the balcony here yesterday was
absent from today's service after
feeling some discomfort she watched the
service on the television at home at
windsor castle today her majesty avoided
st paul's grand steps and long walk down
the aisle but she didn't avoid harry
megan and the kids
a source confirms the e.t the queen met
with archie and lillabet yesterday and
is expected to see lillabet again
tomorrow for her birthday her youngest
great-grandchild will turn one today i
spotted harry and megan leaving clarence
house which suggests they met with
charles and camilla but it's unlikely
they brought archie and lilybert with
them now tomorrow is of course a major
star-studded event the platinum party at
the palace and behind me rehearsals are
in full swing and the lineup is very
impressive
sir rod stewart adam lambert alicia keys
and diana ross will all take the stage
during the two and a half hour concert
and while her majesty did appear in
person last night for the lighting of
the jubilee beacons she won't attend any
of saturday's events the queen won't be
going to tomorrow's horse races at epsom
and she won't be at the party at the
palace here on sunday we have the
platinum jubilee pageant which will
culminate here whether we get to see our
platinum queen one last time during
these celebrations well we'll just have
to wait and see
the chitchat with the queen oh yeah
something you gotta get ready for tom
hanks who once attended a dinner with
the queen revealed on bbc's the one show
just how the monarch likes to party i
dare to ask the queen and what is your
majesty's
cocktail of children okay and she said
martina
[Music]
you